well joining me now is the organizer of
battle lives matter protests Iman 8
former head of Royal protection died
Davis and talk TV presenter Sharon
Osborne Over in Los Angeles Sharon great
to have you on the program
um I don't know about you I got about
halfway through the first installment of
this wine-a-thon last Thursday and felt
genuinely nauseous I mean I could feel
vomit Rising inside me but also a sense
of tedium like we'd heard it was before
with Oprah nothing really seemed that
new it was just a new gloss but on all
this stuff but the main purpose of it
just seemed to be to attack the royal
family to attack the institution of the
monarchy to attack Britain as a racist
country what do you make of all this
it was all very distasteful peers I was
totally bored by The Whining The Whining
the whining and you know the curtsy the
thing she said about Medieval Times her
lunch with the queen was like Medieval
Times which as you know is a Disney type
um entertainment place for kids and it's
just so horribly disrespectful and just
a wine vest I mean what is the book
going to be the same thing whining
whining is there going to be no positive
points and that whole thing of him
um
filming himself on the freedom flight
they must have had that deal with
Netflix done months before they ever
left so the whole thing was a setup a
setup a setup why unless you had a deal
why would you have done that filming of
yourself on the plane and all of that so
what kind of Freedom video diary what
yeah and what kind of freedom is it if
all you're doing is living in your
California mansion with unbelievable
privilege and wealth and you're signing
all these deals with companies who want
their pound of Flesh and that pound of
flesh is exclusively trashing your
family
I mean this is all they do from the
Oprah interview onwards all they've done
is trash their family
is trash but there's nothing about
themselves you know and this is a great
time for them to keep talking about
their charity but no it's about them
being these poor little children who are
so much in love and how abused they've
been their race the way they act
everything has been you know abused by
the public by the Press by the royal
family well do you know what you've got
a great life you've got a beautiful
family you're so much in love move on
get a life move on
and they just can't seem to because
they're living is by telling their truth
on the royal family that's how they make
their living yeah
um their truth is yeah I know I agree
um Dave is on the question of their
security specifically because you were
obviously responsible for a lot of Royal
security for many years Harry claims
that they were sort of had their
security all taken away is that even
remotely likely to have been true
well no the answer is absolutely not the
uh Protection Team followed them to
Canada it was when they moved from
Canada to the United States somebody far
higher than I in my present role or my
old role decided along with a committee
that decides this called ravac they
decided that it was no longer
sustainable for British police officers
to continue and I totally and utterly
agreed and can I say the last time you
and I spoke we were talking about the
lies that Uncle
um his Uncle Andrew put across and here
we are again as an investigator as you
rightly have said and many others there
are so much inconsistencies in this
there are so many half truths and my
concern is as I said having had some
information from Texas as to the number
of individuals there who have believed
this Hook Line and Sinker yeah and if
you know your history of attacks on the
Royal family as I do then you would
start to realize this is potentially
very serious indeed not only for the
royal family but for a fixated person on
either side to get in touch and cause as
it did with President Reagan as it did
with their Majesty a queen last
Christmas a man with a crossbow
etc etc every year over a thousand
referrals are made to the fixated threat
Assessment Center most of them are
harmless but amongst them there is a
hardcore who could pose serious risk and
that's what I've been concerned about as
a consequence of this nonsense that's
been spewed out by these two and some of
their supporters yeah I completely agree
okay look Martin we've had some a lot of
you know animated debate about this and
I completely respect a lot of the stuff
that you've been saying vice versa uh my
issue with this is I I'm not sure what
the supposed end game is or how much
more of this was supposed to stomach I
mean this is another three hours of
trashing coming on Thursday then the
book then a series of interviews around
the book this is just a never-ending
stream of attacks on their own family
I appreciate that's how you feel but
ultimately what they're really doing is
highlighting the disgusting elephant in
the room that the majority of this
nation are more than happy to ignore and
that's what's happening right now and
they're trying to do it in a way that
allows them to look after their family
basically so if it means making money
once they do it what is that elephant in
the room
racism racism in terms of racial
Prejudice within institution and racism
in terms of this country being racist
but I said to you the other day when
things got a bit heated at this desk
that I felt that if you're going to make
incredibly serious charges of racism in
an institution like the British royal
family and the monarchy you've got to
provide some evidence they've now had a
year and a half or more since the Oprah
Winfrey interview in which they made all
these incendiary claims they've not
produced any evidence of any racism okay
so what I'm hoping is that these next
set of documentaries they will actually
provide us with some names so we can
kind of stop this if it doesn't well
what I'll do is I'll provide you with my
evidence is that all right if you give
me a minute I'll give you some evidence
as to why this that specific institution
is racist which I can do so in terms of
the evidence that you are likely to find
it is going to be in the form of covert
racism and I know you don't like that
word but it is a fact so examples
include in terms of the institution the
distribution of the order of sense
Michael which is a badge which
ultimately depicts a white man with
wings trampling a black man we can also
delve into the fact that that
institution hung up pictures of a little
black slave boy on the Walls Within the
institution and everyone was so blinded
by their racial Prejudice that no one
saw fit to take it down when the black
president popped around for tea or we
can delve into the fact that the Queen
Elizabeth or rather the lake Queen made
sure that she did not have to adhere to
the equalities rules and legislation
which is arguably what a true racist
would do and we cannot take away the
facts
exactly in the true races no I'm saying
it's arguably what a true racist would
do
she couldn't have been a less racist
person okay if she had tried okay ask
anyone in any of the commonwealth
countries about the queen none of them
ever felt the queen was a racist yes
when you say things like that you lose
me I'm like that's that's a ridiculous
thing to say okay so I'll explain it so
racism was the building blocks for the
transatlantic slave trade a trade that
was funded by the royal family and they
ultimately made their wealth off of
Blood Sweat and Tears off of enslavery
it was this country that actually led
the end of slavery which Everyone likes
hundreds of years ago by the way but you
also contributed to it and what you fail
to realize is that the legacy of
colonialism slavery and British
politeness a vital role in the
perpetuation of covert racism in other
words the present-day racism that I talk
about today which is in the form of
covert race so would you just so you've
described the late queen as a
effectively a true racist and you think
the country is racist okay so if anyone
that doesn't think that this country is
racist no no are we a racist country or
are we a country that actually is
remarkably tolerant has extraordinary
Multicultural Society but includes some
racist people which one is it so if you
don't think this is a racist country you
should probably speak to Diane Abbott
the black footballers who have the
contender of racism on a daily basis or
we can delve into 85 000 people who
you're saying because a few people can I
just finished yeah yes or we can delve
into the 85 000 people who reported
racially motivated hate crimes in 2021
and it's subsequently gone up to 100 000
right or we can delve into the 120 000
people have left their jobs in the last
five years due to racism or we can delve
into the quarter of staff and 56 of
students within higher education that's
have to contend with racism or if none
of those are accepted would you I'm
happy for you my platform if I can
receive after this I have no I do not
dispute for a moment there are vile
races in this country I don't dispute
for a moment if you troll enough on
social media you'll find them but I do
think they are the ugly little Barnacles
peering out from rocks I don't believe
that they are actually what this country
stands for I don't believe the vast
majority of people in Britain are racist
I don't think we're an institutionally
racist country and I certainly don't
think the queen had a racist bone in her
body which is why she's such a beloved
figure in the Commonwealth so can I just
add that again I said it to you last
time this country has a very rudimentary
understanding of racism often referring
to overt racism as the defining Factor
foreign
racism is you end up with people like
Meghan Markle who say I was a victim of
racism but don't feel they have any
compulsion to have to say what actually
happened when it happened and who said
it and that is if that's covert racism
the problem with it is there's no hard
fact to support it but that's the issue
with okay so firstly I will preface my
statement by saying I agree with you it
should be known that's that's a fact it
should be known as she should make a
point of saying it I really do hope that
she does But ultimately like I said this
is about her highlighting a truth for
truth that many people are failing to
acknowledge and like I said
an odd frame of rest Sharon look these
are pretty incendiary comments from Iman
here that we are a racist country that
the queen effectively was a true racist
covertly or otherwise I mean I find
those comments pretty offensive what do
you think
I think that as in every country in this
world there are a sects that are
anti-semitic racists there always will
be no matter what they always will be
because there's good and bad in every
race there's always a little group of
these nasty little evil people that
dislike someone because of color or
religion those are the two main dislikes
so yes there is a certain
minority in England that are very racist
and a very anti-semitic okay and I can
say that being a Jew so the thing is
it's never going to end it hasn't ended
for thousands of years why should it end
now but you carry on you don't get these
people a platform
you'd want to talk about somebody with a
platform Kanye West he is he has
millions of followers that follow him
that adore him and will do what he wants
them to do you see I actually think I
actually think Meghan Markle country is
an overall racist no and I think Meghan
Markle branding is a racist country and
attacking the institution the monarchy
is racist I think I think actually I
think she is she is what I would call a
race beta if she doesn't produce hard
evidence to support these incendiary
claims she becomes a race beta
exploiting racism and the issue of
racism to act as a kind of protective
shield around her and to make herself
extremely rich and famous as a
professional victim last word to die
Davis die just as somebody who has been
around the royal family for many many
years how do you feel about the way the
reputation of the royal family is being
so reduced in this way
well I'm appalled frankly uh some people
see racism around the corner uh racism
is in Africa it's in India it's in every
continent and so to pick on the royal
family in this way is both insulting
it's also insulting most of the media
are very decent people I know a huge
amount of people for the last 50 odd
years in the media most like you and I
are decent people to vilify both the
Royals the media and the nation and
somehow imply we're all racist is
nonsensical in my opinion and I I just
despair that there are so many who will
take the word of proven liars and then
translate it into this issue about
racism and you were around the queen a
lot on this suggestion that she was some
covert racist herself what do you say to
that
unbelievable nonsense
thank you di appreciate you joining me
thank you Sharon uh over there in LA
hope to catch up with you soon thank you
Mom for joining me I appreciate it